First Lady Melania Trump will reportedly
visit immigration facilities near the
us-mexico border today now this is her
second visit since President Trump
signed an executive order ending family
separations last week near the border
federal agents in Edinburg Texas allowed
David beg no inside a home during a raid
of smuggled undocumented immigrants
David good morning Gail good morning
it's another layer of the border crisis
story over the last two weeks that we've
been here starting when you came down
here we showed you where people are
crossing the border every day every hour
but this involves smugglers stashing
people in houses we're in the middle of
a nice neighborhood in the middle of
town in this case the smuggler was
arrested told police where he'd find the
immigrants and even gave him the garage
door opener
nearly two dozen law enforcement agents
surrounded this suburban Texas home
early Wednesday morning
the deputy chief was just told that
there's about 40 people inside is
exactly what they had been pulled inside
62 undocumented immigrants mostly from
Central America and Border Patrol says
they were brought here by a smuggler
every inch of tile in this house had
someone sitting on
when the agents do you know what
happened this woman who was here with
her sister says she'd been in the house
for 15 days every one of these people
that is be smuggle is paying about
$9,000 and that money goes through the
cartels and continues fueling this
cartel violence every person was given a
clear bag for their belongings then
patted down inside the house they were
led outside hands behind their head
headed to a bus and then a processing
center in McAllen Texas the conditions
are so bad they will call 911 that's how
we were able to uncover some of these
stash houses because somebody is so
desperate to get out if they're willing
to call to rescue them
Border Patrol told me that what
smugglers will usually do is go on
Craigslist or find a newspaper ad
they'll rent the house and in many cases
the owner doesn't even know what the
smuggler is using it for heck the
neighbors don't even know I mean Vlad
the woman who lives across the street
asked us what we were doing here we told
her and she said I had no clue I mean I
live right across the street and to
think that there were 60 people living
in this house one man said he was here
for nearly a month by the way there's
only one bathroom one shower disturbing
details indeed David beg no for us thank
you very much